my meeting sorry
nice to meet you me Chris Chris
I voted to mean why did you vote to
remain things aren't that bad
more things will go bad then I wasn't
reluctant remain or shy out I was out
and proud
make people know that we're not happy
for them and some maybe didn't think it
would quite go as far as it did
badump Isaac people didn't know what
they wanted and Isaac you think I've had
people just like talk to me on the train
go I'll God all for what happened and
I'm like no no it isn't it's great
you're all about anyway avenged I know
yeah I can't wait I'm gonna play popcorn
just about to be first out the door okay
so I'm in the middle you know it'd be
both take the stand O'Connor the crowd
the longer we stayed in the closer we
get to a super state and the harder it
would be to eventually the European army
medics
scaremongering I can hear not really
voted until the last couple of years and
then sort of the the objects that thing
was the most that I've cared about any
political thing yes I had anything to do
with me back control not to sound like
that what you taking back control of
those three things changing for the
better
just it's like a moral question I mean
it obviously things aren't gonna change
overnight but in 30 years or so we'll
look back on the European experiment and
the same kind of amusement is our
parents love pit you know witch hunting
and that is true all those other things
that in hindsight look completely
bizarre that's what it was quite similar
destined to fail I'd you know I thought
you'd be more compassionate remainer but
you just came kind of children yeah
reluctant Romina if I put you on
slightly the brexit path okay I tried